foreign
hey everybody happy Sunday what's going
on with you guys probably what you're
talking about nope yeah we finally got
around to seeing this God damn it yeah
it turned up on Amazon Prime yeah I'm
kind of glad we didn't pay to see it I
mean it's not a bad movie it's not one
of his best
it has some weird angles it had a lot it
has [__] I like them like this [__]
inexplicable monster
it was truly alien what they show you
know how they showed this thing I
couldn't figure out what it was
I just saw the things that it did
um yeah this is probably gonna have like
some spoilers because I kind of feel
like this is a good movie
to go into Without Really knowing what
to expect and I think that they they
were really actually successful when
they were marketing it because I
remember like when it was coming out
back in 2022 and I remember seeing all
the trailers for it and I'm like what
the [__] is that movie even but it's
like it looked really intriguing because
they kept everything very ambiguous and
like mysterious and I think that was a a
good way to go because everybody was
like what the [__] is this like we gotta
see this movie and it ended up making
like a you know all the money like a
[__] ton of money it made a lot of money
uh 171 million yeah
it was uh it was decent uh it's kind of
starts slow if you ask me though
um it's a bit long I will say that
longer than it has to be it's not an
action movie
it it
um the stories build up is kind of
character driven I guess
yeah
um but the characters for me or they're
not that compelling
most of the situation is not that
compelling it's not compelling until the
stamped Flying Saucer [__] starts
showing up it gets a little bit better
they show you they show you some weird
[__] happening in the very beginning to
try to put a hook in you
but takes a long time for the payoff
um
so the pacing feels a little off if you
ask me
um but a decent flick decent flick
the the alien monster [__] was a good
design because it was just so unique
yeah I mean this is gonna have spoilers
if you haven't seen this movie like I
said it's better to go into it not
knowing what to expect really
um so this is kind of gonna have I don't
know if we're gonna spoil spoil it but I
mean we're gonna have to talk about like
something I don't understand
it's um I will say that unlike I did
okay I didn't like it as much as get out
or us but I will say that this movie
um unlike get out or us which seemed
like that it was pretty I mean us was a
little bit uh uh weird like a little bit
ambiguous but you didn't have to think
too hard to like figure out like the
underlying metaphor like what he was
talking about I kind of feel like this
one even though I kind of got it
um it's a lot more open to
interpretation and it's a lot subtler I
feel like than his other two movies yeah
I know the thing was eating people
I'm not really sure how they killed it
or why it died
there is it does a lot of [__] there's
no explanation there's just some alien
[__] that it does
which is kind of weird I think it's kind
of accurate if you ever came across an
alien an alien creature you probably
wouldn't understand what you were seeing
um
it
I don't know I guess it's spoil it I
mean at first it looks like a flying
saucer but then you realize that sucking
up people out of the ground using a
vacuum and then blowing the dirt back
out of its mouth
because it's got a mouth or something in
the bottom of it
and then over time it just unfolds into
this big
wispy
kite-like looking thing
yeah make geometric shapes out of its
[__] skin that look impossible I
don't know I guess it was talking I
don't know well I think what it was was
that um he well he used like for the
monster design like he actually used
um kind of uh sea creatures largely and
I think that the the fact that it had
that square yeah eye slash mouth or
whatever he said I read somewhere that
um he got that idea from like a
biologist that told him that octopus and
stuff like that like actually had square
eyes and also I think he was trying to
evoke a camera shutter okay because
there was kind of a lot of I mean it
looked like a camera shutter like the
thing's mouth slash
was it all one thing I'm not really sure
it just had one opening like a lot of
sea creatures but yeah it did kind of
like unfold a lot and I think too they
were kind of maybe he was kind of like
subtly referencing that um the um what
do you call it the praying mantis like
earlier that was like on the camera you
know what I mean that maybe
so I think that maybe that's hard to say
um and then it it uh it did some other
cool [__] too what was it they killed it
in a weird way I don't know how it died
but it did it did kill it
um it's just a lot of things weren't
explained about its biology you were
just kind of left-handed yeah and yeah
and it didn't really say like how long
it had been here so but like I said I
don't really think that needs to be
explained necessarily I think it's weird
yeah it makes it like weirder it was
hiding in a cloud they noticed that what
cloud was always there and it would
never go away like yeah it would have
been there for like months yeah it was
in that cloud on the horizon and it
would come out and eat people
you guys said I like this movie because
it tried something different but get out
is my fave yeah I think of all of them
get out as still my favorite one but I
like that Jordan peel is making these
weird ambitious films and it's like
people are going to see them so he's
like being allowed to do that and I
think that's really cool because you
don't usually see these kind of big
budget movies that are as kind of weird
as this one is yeah you can tell um and
he didn't make a secret about this
either because he's like a big film buff
um but he was uh inspired a lot by
Steven Spielberg's films particularly
Close Encounters of the Third Kind which
this is kind of like
um also signs the M Night Shyamalan
movie
um Jurassic Park Jaws like those kind of
like monster movies King Kong uh he said
he used that and also uh Wizard of Oz
also a lot of people have pointed out
that um there's like a lot of anime in
this one which I don't know if it's
Akira but it's like another one but he
makes like a lot of references to like
some uh some anime in this as well
because he's a big fan of that Keith
Davids makes a cameo appearance in it
just for a few seconds and he's gone but
I think there should have been more
Keith David
yeah are you sure that was him at least
by the voice it was it was the show it
was him yeah yeah he was only yeah he
played like the main character Daniel
kaluya play he played his dad and so he
was only in it like at the beginning and
then spoiler alert he gets killed like
he's killed a few minutes yeah like in
the first few minutes and then I think
they show him again like later on like a
flashback yeah but I think what they're
talking about Jeffy art says uh with a
background in post and VFX
the movie themes resonated with me with
its depiction how VFX and BTS crew get
treated and exploited in the industry
something that continues to this day and
I think that that was one of the themes
I think they were kind of two themes
going on with this I think that the main
theme was kind of about
the end like the movie industry and how
it exploits kind of the people on the
bottom like you said like people that
just like work on the movies like behind
the scenes like you know the main
character in this movie are you know
horse Wranglers and they get kind of
treated like crap and other things like
of that nature and I think that the
monster too is kind of a metaphor of
like Hollywood like chewing people up
and spitting them out because that's
like what the Monster does literally
um and also Steven yoon's character uh
who you know was on the set of like as a
child actor was on that TV show where
the chimp went ape [__] with chip [__]
and uh you know mangled all those people
and killed those people but he survived
and and yet because he was the Survivor
later on like when he grew up he also
like exploited that tragedy like for his
own gain like opening up his own Park
and also there's a thing too the other
theme which is sort of related is about
how
how maybe you think that you can control
the uncontrollable like animals what
they're talking about that's why the the
characters are horse Wranglers and
there's kind of a whole thing about
training the horses and like one of the
horses you know kicking out after OJ
tells them hey you know don't look him
in the eyes or whatever and I think
there's a thing too where Steven yeun's
character Jupe he thinks because the
chimp didn't kill him at the beginning
that he can tame and exploit this alien
creature for his park because he got
away with that you know what I mean so
jean jacket is what they end up killing
they they end up calling the alien which
like they named after like a horse that
they talked about it was like a whole
scene
but yeah so
um I definitely like I think this is a
movie that and I've heard this from
other people they're like they if you
watch it more than once and I think this
was also true of us
um you pick up a lot more of the
subtleties because when I was like
reading other people's reviews and like
other things about it there's a lot more
detail in there than it appears I guess
like At first blush but you just really
have to be paying attention to like pick
up on it that said I do think the build
up was a little slow yeah
um because I think that they kind of I
don't know if they kind of marketed this
as a horror movie and it's not really a
horror movie it has horror elements
especially toward the end but I'm not
actually really sure what genre I'd call
it it's sort of marginally a sci-fi
movie yeah
um actually Wikipedia calls it a
neo-western science fiction horror film
which okay I mean it does have like
Western elements to it as well so it's
just kind of hard to classify which I I
usually like stuff like that like people
that kind of experiment with different
totally in a lot of places it reminded
me of like one of the early versions of
uh what was the name
[__] what was what was the series that
had the tremors yeah like yeah it's
taking place out in the desert there's
some kind of weird alien monsters
instead of underneath the ground it's in
the sky
and then they gotta go kind of fight
this thing it kind of reminded me a
little bit of Tremors
but only I guess only in certain tones
only in the tone of certain scenes
tone of the dialogue's a lot different
um
it's kind of kind of slow in the
beginning and a lot of the stuff seemed
unnecessary at the time but though if
you probably go back and watch it it
probably has a significance yeah I think
that's kind of what it is and I I do
kind of feel like like I said I do kind
of feel like there was a lot of stuff
going on in this movie yeah and I'm not
sure a lot of it didn't look like it was
necessary right and maybe if you go back
and watch it again like you'll pick up
all the connections between because I
think that I picked up a lot more the
second time we watched us because we saw
that in the theater twice the whole
chimp story didn't seem to be necessary
there's a lot of stuff that didn't seem
to be necessary uh referring back to the
damn horse that was not trainable I just
it
he's trying to give a message there but
I don't think it was necessary
um well you know yeah it didn't Nest it
didn't make for a real and enjoyable
movie right I mean I did like the scenes
with the chimp thing yeah but I do think
it it does tie in with a larger
narrative because like I said there it's
it ties in with the whole exploitation
theme because of you know because of
Jupe using the fact that he survived
that tragedy like as a springboard like
to make money later on
no but no but then then what I was going
to say I was gonna finish that was that
um but also because he survived it yeah
uh you know which he saw as miraculous
so he kind of got a little bit up
himself and thought oh well the chimp
didn't kill me so this alien isn't gonna
kill me either like I can tame it and
use it for my own just like he did like
with the tragic battle you're you're a
writer right so you understand that and
that that's that's that's significant to
you but it's just like a
just a regular pedestrian moviegoer it's
kind of like you know as me just sitting
there watching a movie trying to enjoy
it that's that's more information that I
actually need I want to just see him
fight the monster
it's like it was a Tremors Traverse is
basically about fighting a monster yeah
and that's more of what I wanted more
than anything else I didn't really care
about any message behind it like what
what the [__] is the monster where does
it come from how are they gonna kill
this monster
that's kind of how that's kind of what
where I was going you know that's where
my interest was I didn't really care
about any messages behind it well I
don't know if it's necessarily a message
but it's just like a theme I guess yeah
I think those were like the the
interconnected themes right thank you
Jeffy art
uh Danny Rowling said this would have
been better if it were real aliens and a
Starship instead of a creature I don't
know though because I kind of feel like
that's been done a lot I thought the
creature was cool I thought the creature
was cool too and I thought that that was
cool like in the middle that you found
out that it wasn't actually a spaceship
but it was actually like an organic yeah
and it didn't make any goddamn sense it
was doing stuff that was [__] weird
and um that's the way it would be
probably if you saw a damn alien
creature you probably couldn't make
sense out of it
he's like what the [__] is that yeah I
mean it would be completely bizarre you
look like a sheet unfolding in the sky
and it was kind of geometric and then to
blow up never change shapes then it
would do geometric patterns and you just
couldn't make you wouldn't know what you
were looking at
I mean can I say too that the
cinematography in this and the VFX work
and stuff like that was pretty
spectacular and now I kind of wish that
I'd seen this on the big screen because
especially all the night shots and like
all this I mean there were some great
[__] visuals in this it looked
amazing
um Danny Rowling also said this film was
disappointing I wanted to like this film
but didn't peel pretty much ripped off
jaws and close encounters and called it
his own us is definitely his best in my
opinion I really did like us I think
that I probably liked this one less just
because it's more sci-fi and that's not
usually my jam
um so I liked like I said I get out is
still my favorite but us was great just
because it was so creepy and I think
that it was I don't know I think that
the that the it didn't really make a lot
of logical sense either but a lot of
horror movies don't I think that us was
a lot more uh specifically horror themed
whereas this one was less horror and
more sci-fi it did have horror toward
the end like I'm not sure if you had
kind of a nightmare quality to it right
right where nightmares are they don't
make much sense that's what I'm saying a
lot of subterranean stuff right my
nightmares like I get into a closet
notice that there's buttons on the side
of the wall it's like it's an elevator
and press a button it goes down 30
floors underneath the ground and when it
opens up I'm in a 1970s apartment yeah
yeah I've had dreams like that what the
[__] is where is this [__] place
just covered in dust like nobody's been
been down there forever
there's no windows and you're like who
lives down here and it's a whole Warren
and Maze
of rooms like you're in a [__] old
abandoned hotel and you're very confused
about where you are
that's kind of the way us was
yeah and I really do like films that are
able to
uh to accurately portray a nightmare
like that yeah and I think that that
really did have that vibe to it you
weren't sure if it was real or not I
think that really the the nightmarish
imagery in this one was when they
actually showed like the people that
were sucked up inside a jean jacket and
like when he was eating them and he they
were going like through as digestive
tract and stuff and they were all
screaming and [__] that was pretty
alarming but I think that was kind of
like the scariest thing in it so I'd say
that this is more like a thriller I
guess because it's kind of more like a
slow build up it's like you know what is
this thing that they're seeing it's you
know what what is this stuff that's
falling out of the sky and then like
once you
figure out what it is and they're trying
to like film it like I said I kind of
feel like the whole theme of it too not
just exploitation of like you know the
people that you know on the film Crews
and things like that but all of the
characters are also trying to get a
piece of this thing they're all I mean
the two main characters like OJ and
emerald they're trying to film the [__]
so they can get on Oprah and like make
all the money you know what I mean so
and they're doing like really stupid
dangerous things in order to get that
and then there's like other people
wanting to get in on it too like get a
piece of the pie so everyone's just
trying to like hustle to make money off
of
you know whatever the spectacle is even
if it's like really dangerous you know
what I'm saying so I think that that's
kind of another uh theme as well uh Ben
said he liked the movie uh and then
Danny Rowling said the bathroom over the
house scene was good yeah we're like
where the monster comes over and like
basically like poops out like all the
blood and watches and hands and things
like that like over the house which I
think I'm pretty sure that was an homage
to uh War of the Worlds because I think
there was a scene like that in the book
and I think they put that in the Tom
Cruise version did they not it was
spraying out damn spores and stuff yeah
but like similar it was like red yeah
well it had been
um they had been fertilized or not
really fertilized I guess you could say
human blood had been infused with it to
to
um to give it
yeah I'd like to fertilize it
remember that it was a martian red weed
and not only were they
eating the people and drinking their
blood they were putting that blood
inside the Martian weed and the spores
and blowing it out through the tops of
the dam war machines to to terraform the
planet and she Wells do what he was
[__] talking about if aliens came
here and wanted to take this planet
they'd terraform it
they turn it into their own planet where
they left yeah and he included that they
didn't want the Earth as it is
they wanted it as you know they wanted
the Earth in their own light in their
own image in the image of their planet
and Mars red so they just figured it was
a red weed growing all over it like
vegetation
we just like it rad okay yeah but
um slash Fred says since you are
reviewing nope you should review the
sci-fi classic Earth versus the flying
saucers yeah I do kind of feel like we
were getting into doing some 50 sci-fi
and we did a bunch of them but I don't
think we got around to that one so we
eventually will because I do actually
want to I really like that movie
uh Jeffy art said the actor who played
the sister uh that was Kiki Palmer
definitely had Charisma it was
interesting to see how the two siblings
played off each other and how Angel
wanted to tag along yeah I really do I
did like the dynamic between Daniel
kalia's character and Keke Palmer's
character because they were like Polar
Opposites they were like brother and
sister you know he was very uh you know
stoic and it's like he wasn't really
like reacting to much and he seemed like
he was very troubled I guess like by the
dad's death and whatnot and she was just
very outgoing and like a little bit
flaky and you know you could see that
they worked well as a team but that they
were like completely opposite
uh Michael winkot is great in this movie
as always love him on the crow and 1492
the conquest yeah the guy um because you
recognized him immediately as the
villain from the crew right the guy that
plays uh antler's horse who is the
filmmaker who I'm assuming I thought he
was supposed to be like Werner Herzog
you know what I mean where he just like
comes there and he's got like the
hand-cranked camera and he's all like
[__] cynical and everything and then
at the end he wants to get that
impossible shot like he lets himself get
eaten by the alien so you can film the
inside of it [__] like that did he I
mean he knew that that was gonna happen
right that he was gonna get eaten by the
[__] I thought
I mean it seemed like he did it on
purpose
um Hugo said I think he should review
the UFO incident with James Earl Jones
based on real people
I've heard of that but I don't think
I've ever seen it I've been one about
Barney and [__] what's his name Benny
and Barney that got taken Betty and
Bernie Hill yeah this is the thing is
what he's talking about yeah and you
know what now that it's like that's such
a famous case but I don't think I've
ever seen like a fictional movie yeah
based on I think there's one in the 70s
and I think that's what he's talking
about oh yeah maybe so early 70s late
60s well let me write this [__] down
because otherwise I'm gonna forget
everything because like I always do
because it's like I always get all these
recommendations and then I keep
forgetting about [__] oh look it's I'm
all
so the guy wrote down smell of snack
City on this on the back of this thing
yeah I know because we were talking
about the T-shirt or whatever UFO
incident and we also want to do earth
versus the flying saucers
um but yeah so a lot of people I don't
know I kind of feel like
um this was this reminded me most of
Close Encounters it's uh and it had a
very spielbergian kind of quality to it
in some aspects and it did kind of
remind me of signs as well I liked this
better than signs though I'm not a huge
fan of signs it's it's one of uh you
know shyamalan's better movies
but I don't not to be mean but that's
not really saying I didn't like it yeah
um shyamalan's best movies are the
Damned his superhero trilogy
over there four of them four of them
The Sixth Sense might be in that same
universe
yeah I mean the Sixth Sense is still his
best movie yeah the rest of them are
just not all that and some of them are
like really shitty I mean some of them
are really bad and like I haven't seen
some of them I and I didn't hate the
village as much as some people did I
think we reviewed it not too long ago
yeah that one was okay um and I saw that
one in the theater actually and I was
just kind of like well I saw that when I
was like I don't know how I feel about
this was that the one that was the one
where they you think it's in the past
but right right yeah yeah yeah it was
just okay yeah that's what I mean it
wasn't great I still feel like his first
movie was the best one
um you know I did like unbreakable I did
like you know but and signs was okay
unbreakable what was it glass yeah and
then split split yeah those were [__]
great yeah that's the way I would
picture [__] I think that's kind of
real in a way
yeah
that's the way superheroes would be yeah
it'd be like that but some people are
kind of like that I think you know you
call it psychic abilities or special
gifts and [__] I think people like that
do exist it's just very rare but that's
just the thing is there's a lot of [__]
that they did was within human
parameters yeah it was just odd you know
very odd and that's the way a superhero
would really be
Ben says science is his best in my
opinion I mean that's not that's that's
a fine opinion to have it's like that's
not I don't I actually don't dislike
signs I just it's not my favorite movie
of his and I'm not but like I said I'm
not the person to like ask about it
because I'm not super super into sci-fi
or alien invasion movies like I've liked
a lot of them but it's not usually the
genre that I would go to with and that's
why I think that I didn't like this
movie quite as much as his other two
because the other two I mean get out was
kind to me came across like very much
like The Stepford Wives uh type of vibe
which I was really into
and US was just its own kind of
nightmarish weird [__] that didn't
really Remind Me of anything else it was
like pretty original
um and I love doppelganger [__] like
that doppelganger [__] is like really
really scary to me so I think that one
kind of hit all my buttons whereas like
at this movie I think it's like a great
movie it's very ambitious and like I
said I really like that there's a
filmmaker out there this high profile
that's still making [__] that's kind of
weird like this because a lot of times
the weirder movies they kind of get
relegated to you know low budget kind of
[__] but Jordan peels movies make money
and like they get a lot of Buzz and a
lot of people go see them so he's kind
of allowed to
uh to kind of experiment and that's
awesome I mean even when the experiment
isn't entirely successful it's almost
kind of like uh today's version of the
way uh [__]
John Carpenter used to be you know when
he was good yeah yeah and a lot and I've
heard like some people compare that
compare him like experimental right
experiment with some [__] and I would
rather see that a million times than
just see like another movie that's fine
but it's just like a bunch of other ones
I mean this one obviously wears a lot of
its influences on its sleeve like I said
but he's pretty open about the movies
that he used as inspiration for this and
it's doing its own thing I mean I really
do like I did like the twist of it not
being a spaceship because at first I'm
just kind of like so it's just an alien
spacecraft which like I said not all
that original and not my favorite Trope
um but then the fact of it being like an
animal I thought that was like a cool
idea and it's I'm sure it's been done
before but not that often so I thought
it was like a good Twist on it yeah but
I guess it was just something that just
came out of space and decided to live
here yeah and I kind of liked that they
left its origin and stuff like because
like I said if you're on the point of
the view of the character I'm a big fan
of like leaving [__] as unexplained as
possible not always but usually because
you explain [__] too much it's not
creepy it's not mysterious it's not
scary anymore you don't give a [__]
anymore yeah um and you're coming at it
from the point of view of the characters
if you're in the characters shoes they
don't know what the [__] where the [__]
this thing came from you know what I
mean they don't know anything about it
so you're just like in the same boat as
they are like reacting to it the same
way that they would and you can put
yourself in the character's shoes then
because you're like well what if this
happened to me like what if I was out on
a ranch and like there was this Cloud
that didn't move and all of a sudden
this big [__] thing was coming out of
it and like sucking people up and eating
all of them like and then [__] them
back out like on top of my house you
know what I mean that would be uh pretty
upsetting yeah it ate a lot of the
horses too which I think they they
didn't go too much into and I didn't
actually catch this until later on in
the movie but that's why you know like
at the beginning like near the beginning
where OJ goes to Joop and asks if he can
buy some of his horses back and Jupe is
just kind of like
um yeah let's not talk about hey look at
my museum and all this other kind of
stuff the reason for that was because he
had been feeding the horses to the alien
okay that's why like I don't think I
picked that up until like later on and I
was like oh I don't think it was an
intelligent alien I think it was just an
animal yeah and that's what they were
saying that he was just like this
unpredictable animal and like all of
these humans including Joop and
including OJ and his sister were trying
to tame the animal or exploit the animal
like for their own gain
um even though it was like super super
dangerous they were like doing all this
dumb [__] you know I I guess because OJ
and M were like oh we grew up training
horses so this is kind of the same thing
and they do kind of defeat it using
those methods but
um jupe's character he thought he could
tame it just because you know the chimp
didn't kill him when he was a kid it was
something on par with like a c an enemy
or a damn
jellyfish and a and a praying mantis
that's what that's what it was
it's what they kept kind of alluding to
it wasn't intelligent it could signal
though it was signaling something with
the square
or maybe it was an eye there's no way of
knowing yeah I kind of thought it was
because at the very beginning like at
the beginning credits you see something
that's like that square green square
thing with like this it's unfolding on
it and it's not but it but you don't
know what that is until like later on
but then like the square kind of goes in
and then they show that the Edward my
bridge
um you know film thing which is like a
famous piece of film history or whatever
so it's kind of like an eye but it's
also like a camera a camera like a
camera eye kind of primitive eye because
there is like a lot of Hollywood history
and that like you know exploitation of
like lower people like in Hollywood and
things like that
um so I think that he was tying a lot of
things in with film camera shutters like
film history things like that so there's
a lot of little [__] like that
um like a lot of little Easter eggs and
I mean and then there was the whole
thing too like when they do the
flashback in the um with the chimp where
that one shoe was like standing up on
its end yeah like and they and then that
kind of refers back to what they were
talking about something being a bad
miracle and also I saw somebody online
that made the um that made the point
that it's like maybe that was like a
metaphor or two for like waiting for the
other shoe to drop like waiting for
something bad to happen uh so it could
have been that as well but you know but
I think that too that tied in with like
the kid you know jupe's character when
he was a kid seeing that it was like a
miraculous thing and also him not
getting killed was a miraculous thing so
he started to get like like he thought
he was invincible and he could just you
know he could just train this huge alien
creature that he didn't know [__] about
just because of that you know what I
mean yeah that's kind of what I took
from it I'm not really sure if that's uh
yeah
uh yeah Ben said the chimp sequences
were really surreal at first yeah you
really do kind of have to when you're
just watching it at first you're just
like what the [__] is going on and what
does this have to do with anything
because it seems like those two things
don't really tie in you don't you don't
find out like how the chimp story like
ties in with the other stuff into like
later on
Danny Rowling said um Jordan peel is
famous for his original style of filming
technique deemed the humans pop filming
style uh Jeff erard said I had to watch
the movie several times to pick up some
of the little details regarding the
story yeah like I said this one seems a
lot more subtle than his other two and
it definitely seems like something that
you'd have to watch like a bunch of
times and you would maybe pick up more
stuff
um
Nicholas uh says the idea that alien
technology may be organic in nature is
an old idea I wouldn't say the crafted
nope is an animal like a sky creature
yeah okay I mean you know
uh talking about sound production yeah
the sound in this was also really good
another reason that I kind of wish that
I'd seen it on the big screen I actually
intended to but we just never got around
to it uh Ben said it was also about the
reflections from stuff making tame
animals go nuts the horse for instance
yeah because that was
um yeah like looking in the horse's eyes
and everything like that that was kind
of like a big thing that uh because that
was that was how you kept the jean
jacket from eating you evidently yeah I
guess if you looked at it it would get
you that doesn't make sense but
maybe well the thing of Faith well and
it was the same thing as they were
talking about before I think like you
were in the bathroom mirror during that
one scene but like when OJ was like at
the horse like at that um on that set
where they were filming that commercial
and he kept telling all the other people
on the crew like don't look in the
horse's eyes like don't look in the
horse's eyes and then like one idiot
like put like a mirror thing like right
up into the horse's eye and then it
kicked out like and you know so he got
fired so
um so I think that that was all kind of
like tying back into not showing the
animal any aggression I guess because a
lot of animals take if you look them in
the face including chimps uh if you look
them in the face then they take that as
a sign of aggression and will attack you
and I think that was tying back to the
chimp thing too because even though the
kid you know he was hiding under the
table like during the chimp Rampage
um but and he looked the Chimp in the
face but there was like a there was like
a partial um like a tablecloth like in
between so he couldn't quite see through
so he wasn't exactly looking at him you
know what I mean so maybe that's what it
was too but yeah it's on if you have
Amazon Prime
um and you liked his other movies then
it's definitely worth watching like I
said don't go into it expecting it to be
a horror movie because it's really not
and I do think that the build up was a
little bit slow but I'm willing to
concede that I you know would probably
end up watching it again at some point
and I will probably pick up a lot more
stuff I didn't like it as much as his
other two but that might be just be
because it's more sci-fi and I'm not you
know that's not really my favorite
subgenre
but Jeffy art said the part with the
reflection reminded me of when a male
turkey kept attacking my car because it
saw itself on the surface
we I know this is terrible but when we
were kids
um you know you could get those like
what they used to call Siamese fighting
fish yeah and you can really only keep
one at a time if you don't know you can
only keep one in a tank they're
beautiful but the male ones are like
super aggressive and if there's another
one like in their territory then they'll
just tear each other up so a lot of
times like little kids if you want to be
mean and cruel then you hold a mirror up
to the fish tank and then the fish will
like bang itself like against trying to
get that other you also can't put them
in a big tank they'll jump out yeah you
got to keep them in a little bitty tank
they revolved they need to settle down
they they they
evolve to be basically in like a damn
hoof print a cow hoof print filled with
water that's that's where they meet they
live in a dam yeah they like small
spaces a little glass of water if they
if everything else out if they get like
in in too big of an area they get like
agoraphobia or something and they're
just like that's too much they're
waiting for a female to jump in
that's what they're doing the male jumps
in they fight try to force each other
out get out of it yeah I think they come
near they're from they're from around
those rice paddies wherever they come
from so they yeah and they each have
their own little [__] puddled
which is funny it's just like little
here's when I accidentally like jumped
it I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah I need to
force them out
Danny Rowling said what's tomorrow's a
haunting episode gonna be I think we're
gonna do blood Visions from season
that's season five episode one because I
was looking through all the um the
episode lists and there's not really a
lot left in the one to four thing that
we haven't already covered at some point
so I'm guessing that we're gonna have to
start on season five and I remember
blood Visions being an okay episode but
I think that's the first one of season
five so we'll probably cover that one uh
tomorrow if it changes I'll let you know
but other than that it's probably not
going to so because we gotta watch it
tonight in an hour but uh but yeah so
hopefully you guys have uh enjoyed this
little discussion of Jordan peele's nope
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
have a good rest of your weekend and
we'll see you then bye